hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to h1z1 this game has been
so unbelievably requested of me and I've
been so unbelievably hesitant to play it
because if you know me at all and you
know these types of games you know that
these types of games aren't exactly for
me however I'm very curious about it
because I don't know much about it and I
am kind of a little bit biased in that I
did not have a great experience with
Daisy
however you guys loved me playing Daisy
way back two and a half years ago when I
had a much smaller channel so I'm gonna
get back into it this is really dramatic
music but worry not I'm not gonna flail
around like an idiot I don't have any
progress on my character right now this
is more gonna be of a kind of a
documentation style video of my
adventures in this game and how I
struggle to survive as I learn to play
so I'm going to be clueless no frankly I
am clueless about a lot of things is
that a Shack I heard that people can
build their own bases so I actually have
no idea what to expect I have no idea
what's in store for me and that surprise
factor is going to play a lot into my
own fears because like many games that I
play and start out in and have no idea
what I'm doing
and I usually flare around like an idiot
for a long time and people get angry at
me in the comments I just stick with it
and I go for it but this time I'm here
to learn so watch along there's gonna be
a lot of cuts I'm going to explore this
world document my feelings and maybe
give you advice on how not to behave in
a big server filled with other
bloodthirsty people who want to kill me
at every turn okay I see a town that's
where I'm headed first because obviously
the population centers are gonna be
where all the items are or all the
people are and we're all the zombies oh
there's another present oh I didn't want
to meet someone else's early I did read
at least this particular game can have a
lot more people people veterans have who
have been playing this already are going
to be very miffed and act at my poor
playstyle but I'm just a little bit
worried because if anybody has gun
they're probably gonna shoot me directly
in the face
I don't even know like I always wonder
this in these open-world multiplayer
type games if my mic is open and hot
than everybody on the server or in the
general area could hear me rambling to
myself so I'm kind of apprehensive to do
anything else that ad or floating in the
middle of the bush over there probably
yeah it's player can you hear me sir
who are you trying to fight I'll put up
my dukes I ain't afraid of you yeah if
you knew where I was I'd be punching the
crap out of you but you don't probably
I'm an idiot hey is that a deer I'm
gonna go say hi to the deer or maybe
I'll just go to the farm try to find
something who is another deer I'm gonna
punch the crap out of that deer come
here you you deserve to get punched
that's right you better run away Paula's
gonna lay down the fists of fury on your
butt your stupid little wait hey I don't
see nothing I'll put it back I'll beat
you grabber you I don't care who I'm
gonna put you right to gether oh yeah
right who's running who's running now
huh who's afraid
yeah that's right yeah you think you buy
me huh I love your MLG Pro up in this
[ __ ] this is like MMA my first
encounter with another person and they
immediately yeah yeah what now huh Punk
yeah yeah I did it I'm a winner I'm a
winner one day one of h1z1 markiplier
wins I really do think that other people
can probably hear me cuz that would be
really weird if I was just screaming in
his face the whole time that I was
beating his face in but I did it now
obviously you can so I I do have a Hut
it's down on the bottom right a little
health bar down there not much man they
really do pump up the minimal Hut in
this game
I want no hug low ammo and enemy said
[ __ ] nightmares okay someone who is
that another person or is that zombie hi
are you Azam Bri are you here to
Oh search all cabins okay there's a
searching mechanic okay so things aren't
just out in the open that's definitely
going to be oh there's nothing here but
I do have a bunch of stuff event tree
what the hell is that what are these
things I don't know what these are
does it seem like there's a lot of crap
here then again it's probably been
scavenged all over the place I mean
there's other players probably here that
I need to punch very hard in the face
and I'll get to the punching of things
very hard in the face eventually but I'd
rather punch things in the face with
bullets like that's just my personal
philosophy when I'm an apocalyptic
situation I prefer it prefer to throw
things in their face that are metal and
going about 500 miles an hour just know
that's me generic immunity boosters I
don't know what that do nothing to the
fridge Oh mom's pink salmon my mom's
alive that's not a good sound I'm very
scared for my life
don't kill me I'm a nice guy I'm a nice
I'll put you in the face I'm gonna put
you oh that did not go well for me what
you got my mom's pink salmon I didn't
have anything I didn't have anything
what if they can hear me I've no idea if
you can hear me nod your head up and
down alright thank you for your input
this is gonna go great
oh look is that a zombie okay
so there is crafting apparently because
I just saw in the bottom left that
there's crafting available in this I
don't know if me shouting up to the wait
is there like a button I can press they
can have a debate the thing no I don't
see anything oh I got all my HUD though
okay let me see if I can use this like
airdrop ticket because that seems like
something that would be good right it's
probably also gonna call attention to
people in the general area but if we can
get me supplies get me stuff maybe I
could punch a tree nope I can't even
punch the tree who's it what is this
this is somebody's cabin there's
somebody home I'm here to take your [ __ ]
you better have some [ __ ] for me god no
it's empty huh well somebody wants to
live all alone isolated in the woods Hey
that I'm the mad puncher I'm the mad
Forrest puncher anybody want to get near
me you're gonna get punched preferably
in the facial region or the dick
whenever one or the other golfer heard
up there we go okay my delivery is on
the way where whoa oh come on I just I
just called it no no sir sir I only
punch humans in the face I don't want to
bother punching with you no no he can't
even find me he's so stupid or maybe he
heard me yelling because that would also
be an alternative yeah I escaped him so
where the balls is my air drop cuz I was
told I was gonna have an air drop ooh oh
you can grab wood sticks oh okay I did
not know this so I now have a wood stick
so I can just gather up oh okay I just
needed to press use on the environment
and I would gather up some sticks that
zombie doesn't seem like he's much of a
threat whoa
ah that's the sound of an airdrop yeah
give me give me goodies please I got a
zombie on my butt maybe you can hurry up
a little bit I mean I don't want to rush
you you are time playing at all you
could probably kill me but maybe you can
give me supplies like right now problem
is every player in the goddamn area is
gonna come from miles away to get my
airdrop the sons of [ __ ] are gonna
kill me
listen getting get a gun where is it
there oh so take so long pretty go where
to go where to go hey where to go oh
where to go where to go where to go go
go go go go give me my airdrop where to
go hello there it is
yeah crap okay so the apparently death
is that way this is gonna land right in
the death isn't it yeah just smash
through that tree you don't mind right
through break all the branches on the
way down don't know how the parachute
isn't snaggin okay so no one else is
here
Oh what is that well how is that fear
what is more into Sammy's when the hell
was it gonna explode into zombies who
sued it that Oh
hopefully that other guy is just
distracting him so then I can now get
this don't mind me
don't mind me everybody yeah it's
totally fine yeah oh oh oh oh oh well I
can't carry it I don't know what I got
but I got some I'm out of here baby I'm
out of here
Hey hi guya what are you doing yeah the
guys trying to punch me ain't gonna
happen
I'm punch I'm the I'm the crazy Forrest
puncher oh this guy's still following me
because he's got a bear on him ain't
gonna bother me you just deal with that
bear bear the [ __ ] that [ __ ] got
me killed by the bear that freakin
douche bag the son of a [ __ ] god dammit
I dropped all my sticks and one of the
hell I got from that air drop the air
drop was a terrible idea
alright starting over again huh priority
number one right now I need to find a
gun cuz if I don't find a gun I'm gonna
be defenseless to anybody else that
comes my way which means I'm gonna die
over and over again it's gonna be bad
I'm not gonna do anything
people are gonna yell at me but you guys
wouldn't yell at me right cuz you're all
beautiful adorable awesome intelligent
crazy great gamer people awesome and you
look fantastic today and everything
you're doing is right and you're awesome
and I believe in you and you are the
best uh-oh that doesn't sound good okay
so I think there's another type of town
that I had I'm gonna check to see if
they've got anything valuable this time
around hopefully this water doesn't kill
me good I'm alive so far
uh-oh that's a sambar that's a Zombo nur
Zomba no me yeah that's bad sound
where's the wolf yet I'm getting scraps
of cloth and scraps of metal so that's a
good thing I guess yeah my nose is
running I wasn't crying or anything cool
makeshift hatchet that sounds like a
really cool thing I'm gonna make that
okay I did it
I've got a hatchet
cool now using this warpin I should be
able to kill what I need it sounds like
there's an animal of some kind in here
not an owl hmm my heart is pounding a
million miles an hour oh [ __ ] no don't
don't come out in what cool beer beer
beer beer beer um okay I don't know how
to communicate but I'm friendly too okay
I back away I go this way you go that
way I go this way okay so I'm at my
first friendly person but then again the
last time that I met a friendly person
in one of these heads games they ended
up stabbing me in the back so let's hope
that doesn't happen because I don't want
that to happen I actually like that guy
poor guy he's probably getting mauled to
death oh that's a terrible fate for him
oh [ __ ] that's another player his gun I
think he is again it seems like the cars
have more useful stuff than any building
ever does so I'm just gonna keep going
up two vans and whatnot and scrapping my
stuff up stuff in scraps of metal into
my pants no was it Han I got my buy
knocks let me take a look woah sorry
punch the air very [ __ ] okay looks
like a lot of cars don't see any
movement so it could be a lot of
valuables there could be a gun in one of
them glove boxes maybe although I don't
know if there are rules to where things
spawn probably not I'm being tactical
about this okay so we got another house
up there
looks like someone's built an outpost
real good I imagine that people would
want to build a base around these cars
just in so that they can farm the items
that are in them yo for a farm a cloth
and metal farm maybe those aren't oh oh
[ __ ]
does he have a gun he's got a bow and
arrow who's he of a bow Nero I wish I
had a bow and arrow yeah I'm watching
you oh you got a friend
where is he a friend fight to the death
minions then I shall swoop in
take all of your goods or I'll hop over
this and run away like a big baby oh
you'll get yours next time once I build
up to get my gun it's not gonna be like
that other game where I found a machine
gun right around the corner
oh I just got oh no I kind of I kind of
got a half hold it down whoa
well that was quiet glad that happened
we just throwing these logs that I got
somewhere nowhere damn it
I'll couldn't carry any more logs oh
yeah there there damn it
uh I'll make a satchel that might help
cuz then I could put more stew yeah in
the satchel okay so if I put stuff in
the satchel I have plenty of stuff I can
discover something with the logs no I
cannot because I know [ __ ] okay I just I
just remembered in my crafting menu
actually wooden planks were already here
I needed to turn logs into them so I
don't think logs themselves actually do
anything except make a campfire
obviously but okay so now that I have
those I can discover something with the
wooden planks or nah
ah damn it what the hell the bunch of
baloney grab a medal discover furnace
Hey look at that that's actually
something useful
hi I'm getting somewhere here okay oh I
dropped it okay so let me drop these
wooden planks first the pickup this tiny
itty bitty furnace and then it's gonna
turn really biggie biggie once I put it
out here so place and bam yay I made a
furnace I think that's good I think
that's very good so uh metal bar same
greedy ins inside a lit furnace wood or
charcoal how do i oh okay so if I put
the wooden planks in there that would be
enough and then I quit the lighter oops
what I did it I did it everybody I did
it holy crap I did it I'm doing
something make a metal bar oh [ __ ] ah
poop oh oh it happens automatically cool
no one can I do with the metal bar metal
sheet yay I guess that doesn't help me
at all how's this supposed to help me
alright screw it you know what screw
this screw you not out here
magical furnace and I wish I could take
you but you're easy to make I'm just
scared for my life
ah that's a zombie I was about to finish
up this episode but I gotta run away
very expeditiously ok so that's my first
episode on h1z1 I think I've done fairly
well so far I'm gonna wait until
recording the next one to get your
advice I want to know what I'm supposed
to do because for my first experience
with this I died a great many times I
found that I did craft stuff I found
crap to craft and also I found another
way to die everything so hope you guys
enjoy this let me know what I should do
in the next episode help me survive I'm
going to die otherwise and I'm gonna die
sad and alone
so either way thank you all so much for
watching you actually know what server I
play on now so if you see me here next
time hey don't kill me
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video
Hey